okay so I tried to recycle I've got my
grocery tote bag
I even have solar panels on my roof when
the back of my mind I can't help
thinking just if you this actually make
a difference when it comes to climate
change if you read the headlines you
quickly begin to see that climate change
is a massive problem so is my reusable
bag really good change the world but not
everyone feels that way
this is all of my trash from the past
four years oh my god
this is Lauren singer she runs a website
where she gives tips and answers
questions about living a zero-waste life
okay so you've got tiny little ends and
bits and things yeah you really tell me
everything else that you use for four
years I found some other youth for
totally is compostable infinitely
reusable or 100% easily recyclable you
may look at the extremely eco-friendly
way Lauren is living and find it
inspiring or maybe like me you're
totally skeptical but a lot of what
she's doing is actually pretty simple
when she wants coffee
she brings her own cup or let's say she
wants to buy a pastry she'll put it into
a reusable cotton bag a safety razor
instead of plastic ones there's all this
disposable stuff in our lives that we're
not even thinking about it and what
Lauren's done is find some easy
substitutes everything else ends up in
the jar this is macaroni and cheese
packaging and this was like four years
ago like right when I started that was
that was my weekend at dad's house so
these are I know what the mastic straws
hot job this was a bad day wasn't it you
know actually someone sent that to me in
a mail these aren't huge trash problems
the EPA isn't up in arms about plastic
straws but you can see how these little
bits of waste can really add up the
United States is the number one trash
producing country in the world if every
country lived like the u.s. we need over
four earths to make all the stuff we
consume do you think little things make
a big difference
totally if you reduce single-use coffee
cups from your routine and your a daily
coffee drinker that's 365 cups per year
that's not an insignificant change if
every single person did that that's a
massive shift towards a more sustainable
future
and good policy can encourage this kind
of shift take plastic bags Americans
throw away about a hundred billion a
year but California is trying to change
this three communities have found that
if you offer a plastic bag from 375
percent of people will take it but if
you charge ten cents for a bag only 16
percent taken it's subtle but this
wolfie makes people question whether
they really need a bag and it reminds
people to bring their own communities
across the country of beginning to adopt
this policy and it could create a
large-scale shift if New York City had a
bag fee we could save roughly seven
billion plastic bags a year and without
good policy it can be really hard to do
the right thing so take recycling in a
place like Missoula Montana where I live
you can't recycle glass because doing so
it turns out cost my city too much I
think this is a fundamental flaw of
governments and their relationship with
businesses businesses aren't held
accountable for products that they're
putting into the waste stream so they're
allowed to sell glass in Montana where
there's no adequate recycling and
completely wipe their hands free and not
have to subsidize any infrastructure to
adequately recycle their product so that
responsibility for disposing of that
product falls on you as a resident and
the government that is completely unfair
the funny thing is we used to have this
really great system for dealing with
glass after you're done with a bottle
you would just return it
companies would clean it and use it
again and again around the 1950s
companies began experimenting with
single-use bottles and cans lots of
other things became single used to like
Don Draper here people were just tossing
their garbage wherever and all this
trash started to annoy people do you
remember that very famous commercial of
this Native American he's like going
down a river and there's all this waste
and the tear goes down people
start pollution people can stop it
and it's often credited for
quote-unquote cleaning up America
because we were reminded that we need to
pick up our trash you see this
commercial every Earth Day but it was
actually funded by a group of companies
many of them from the can and bottle
industry the award that states would ban
their single-use products because people
were getting sick of all the trash so
they created this incredible ad which is
very powerful which made us pick up
trash which is actually trash that they
were creating that was the moment it's
I'm not suggesting you shouldn't pick up
trash but as far as I can tell is the
first moment where we shifted this
responsibility from the person selling
the person back that needs to change
really quick and once it does we won't
even have to talk about providing
adequate recycling systems because
businesses will create products that are
easily and conveniently recyclable
because it'll make more economic sense
for them if that burden is put on the
business instead of the consumer and the
government this gets to the heart of the
matter
climate change is a giant problem we're
not gonna solve it without government
and industry taking action we live in
this complicated web of carbon emissions
I mean every single thing we do as
individuals creates pollution it's
overwhelming but there's one simple
policy that could make going green
easier for all of us and it could have
an enormous impact we could put a price
on carbon right now companies can emit
as much pollution as they like we're
basically treating our sky like a giant
sewer as long as it's free to pollute no
one's gonna stop doing it you can't just
go out there and find one source or one
factory one business and shut it down
and clean up your air everybody in a
sense is part of the problem if
companies had to pay for the carbon they
produced it would encourage better
behavior this is what California did in
2006 the state set a cap on carbon and
other greenhouse gas emissions and they
lowered it over the next few years
companies could either reduce their
pollution or pay for carbon allowances
and so far it's worked the state is on
track
to hit its 2020 goal and they're looking
to cut emissions by another 40% by 2030
now California isn't perfect but this is
a huge reduction in emissions it's
really larger than anything a person
could achieve on their own the fears
that were raised by opponents have not
come to pass we've not seen an exodus of
industries from California or people
unable to drive their cars and as the
state cut emissions California's economy
is actually grown by 12% outpacing the
national average going green at this
scale isn't an overnight process people
like Mary Nichols have spent decades
fighting for better policies we
certainly have enjoyed a lot of
political support from all sides I think
that's largely just because the public
in California has demanded that clean
healthy air is something that everybody
ought to have access to so individual
climate action does matter in the sense
that it creates cultural change when
Loren makes a video tutorial or shares
one of her zero-waste
tips on Instagram it has a social ripple
effect do you want everyone to live the
lifestyle you're living I would never
tell anyone how to live their life but
I'd like to show everyone that there are
options but the way that we're told we
have to live in this hyper consumeristic
way isn't the only way we have to live
in order to live in a modern world with
modern luxuries folks like Loren really
helped build the bottom-up support you
need for large-scale transformation look
climate policy can be complicated and
sometimes it can be boring but we need
to solve global warming and to get
better policies like a price on carbon
you need to have public support because
politicians and businesses won't take
action unless people come together and
demand it so you may not be able to fit
all your trash into a mason jar but
psychologists have been developing green
nudges that trick us into being more
green want to know whether they're
working their magic on you visit climate
dot University of California dot edu to
learn more